while it has been just over 24 hours
since the Vegas golden knights won it
all we thank you for joining us at 11
I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus
as we continue those Stanley Cup
Celebrations our site set on one of the
biggest one of all the championship
parade Sasha Loftus joining us live from
the Las Vegas Strip where everything
will be happening on Saturday
Ethan Brian this is a part of the spread
on Saturday night we're of course all
still buzzing after last night's win now
all the fans and organizers I talked to
say this parade is really the perfect
way to celebrate history
it's a night no one will ever forget the
city is it has become the city of
Champions when our Vegas golden knights
became the 2023 Stanley Cup champions
we got the Misfits and then yeah it was
just the people that they don't want
them in we took them in and then yeah
they played their heart out now they're
setting their sights on celebrating with
the community
everyone is invited to party with the
players coaches and team staff during
Saturday's Championship parade the whole
thing starts at 7 p.m at Flamingo in Las
Vegas Boulevard and will travel to
Tropicana then everyone gathers around
nine at Toshiba Plaza it's amazing it's
it's what you hope for it's what you
dream for as an organization Nate Ewell
vice president of communications for the
nights says It's amazing for the
organization but it's also an
opportunity to give back to the fans we
have something special at The Fortress
but to open our doors literally and be
in front of everyone and have everyone a
chance to come out and see the team and
cheer on the team it's really special
another special chance to keep holding
on to that feeling the most exciting
thing that's happened in this city since
I've been here of the ultimate victory
oh
now of course this part of Las Vegas
Boulevard will be shut down in each
Direction between Flamingo and Tropicana
for the duration of the parade on
Saturday now officials also tell me
there will be some safety regulations
similar to those we see on New Year's
Eve those clear bag policies Etc of
course we have more information as we
get it this week on our website
8newsnow.com so keep checking in there
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
news now it